السيد رئيس الوزراء، صباح الخير، هذا عضو الكنيست
جلعاد كاريب للأسف الشرطة
إسرائيل لا تفهم واجبها في السماح لمواطنيها بذلك
الدولة لسماع أسمائكم في أذنيك
المختطفون وبالتالي ليس لدي باريرا هذا الصباح ولكن
الوقوف إلى جانب هؤلاء المواطنين الشجعان
وعقدت العزم على استخدام حصانتي البرلمانية
لكي تسمع أسماء المخطوفين في أذنيك
وأننا بقيادتكم نصل إلى ما هو عليه
حيث تمنع الشرطة الإسرائيلية المدنيين
والكياسة لإظهار الشعور بالتضامن
والضمان الديني لنا ولأخواتنا المحتجزين
بين يدي الحمص والشا أن الشرطة تحت قيادتها وتحت
نسيت قيادة الوزير إيتامار بانكير تعليماته
القانون، وبالتالي نحن أعضاء الكنيست، سوف يساعدونهم
بمساعدة الحصانة
البرلماني هذه أسماء إخواننا وأخواتنا
التي في حوزتي
حماس